in this video we'll be talking about
chromatine imuno precipitation and
sequencing it's also known as
chipseek so chipsi is a method to study
DNA protein interaction in a genome wide
scale this is a technique that can help
us to understand where does a
transcription Factor binds in in a
genomic
location it's a powerful tool to
identify genome wide Association of
several DNA binding prot or
transcription factor or any other
histones let's say so here is a
situation one and two in situation one a
transcription Factor marked here in red
binds to a specific genomic location so
it has a very specific binding site in
the genome it doesn't bind to every site
or many sites in the genome it is also
possible that there is another
transcription factor that binds into
many genomic
locations whatever be the scenario these
kind of questions can be answered
by
chipseek so let's see how this process
work first of all antibody is incubated
against the transcription factor x so we
need an antibody against the
transcription Factor whose binding we
are trying to investigate so in this
case this antibody detects the red
transcription Factor after that there
are too much chromatin associated with
these transcription factors so we need
to sever the the chromatine by
sonication so there are small fragments
of the chromatine which are generated
after sonication that you can see in
Step number
two in Step number three a pull down
experiment is performed where on a
magnetic bead these antibodies are
coated and the portion of the chromatine
which is bound by this transcription
Factor will be pulled down because there
is an interaction between the antigen
and the antibody and it would be use and
the Magnetic pull would be used to pull
down these fraction from the pull down
fraction the DNA fragments would be
recovered so these DNA fragments are
bound by transcription factor x next
question is where does these DNA
fragment belong into the genome so these
fragments would be sequenced and these
is known as reads after these reads are
generated they would be aligned against
the existing genome and then a peak
calling would be performed Peak calling
simply means how many Peak for a genomic
location one can find so basically if
there are let's say 10 fragments in a
particular mapping to a particular
genomic location that means the
transcription Factor highly binds to
that particular region so in this case
if we see here these reads or the
fragments all correspond to this
particular genomic location and these
genomic location can be obtained from
genome assemblies in the uh
databases so this peak height means
house strong would be the binding so
here you can see there is a strong
binding here is a strong binding but
there is no apparent binding in this
particular
region so how does the data look like
data would somehow look like this so you
can see the transcription factor x chap
uh chip peak in this case we can see the
peak is colocalizing with a gene uh and
the promoter of the gene mostly so we
can conclude from this data that the
particular transcription Factor binds to
the promoter region of these Gene do
look at the chip uh chip peaks in other
genomic locations and you won't see much
of that in the other places okay there
are many other applications for example
mapping the transcription Factor binding
epigenetic modification studies histone
modification profiling identification of
enhancer
promoters Etc so be I mean forget forget
about all these applications now let's
try to understand it in bit more details
with some examples in this
case the specific hones are used for the
chipsi experiment so antibody was used
against the h2a Z variant of the histone
and it was note that where does these
histone variant is mapping to it maps to
the promoter of this particular Gene
also H 3.3 which is enriched in a
promote and Gene bodies of actively
transcribing Gene can show us this
particular Gene marked here is active
another chipsi experiment here is serin
5 phosphate of RNA polymerase 2 so serin
5 phosphate phosphorilated RNA
polymerase 2 is an active RNA polymerase
so in this case if you get a lot of Chip
peek all along the body that means this
Gene is actively transcribed so now we
are looking at different different
different chip signatures and by
combining all these signatures we get a
detailed Outlook into the transcription
process so that is the power of chipseek
a it can give you an O overall idea and
deeper insight about transcription also
it can give you a genome wide
understanding about a transcription
factor or a DNA binding protein binding
now often chips are combined with many
other techniques such as attack
sequencing on which I have made a
detailed video so click on the I button
to get that video so often chipseek RN
and ax should be combined together to
understand the transcription Factor
binding the chromatin accessibility and
the gene expression so in this case let
me walk you through this data neuron and
fibroblast are uh kind of compared for
this Gene a transcription profile so in
this case the rnsc data tells us the
expression of Gene a is less in fi blast
more in neurons and if we look at the
chip Peaks you can see the transcription
Factor one particular transcription
factor is binding more in the promoter
present in the neuron and it's not
present that much in the fibroblast so
it's basically a cell type specific
transcription Factor also it can be seen
that the promoter region was much more
accessible in this case so atoi give us
an understanding about accessibility of
the region so the promoter was
accessible now the promoter is bound to
that transcription Factor as a result
there is a gene expression for Gene a
and in the fibroblast the promoter was
not that accessible transcription Factor
also doesn't bind and in this case you
see a very less expression so more and
more layer of information about
transcription is uncovered when
chipstick is combined with other
techniques so I hope this video was
useful and we can talk more about these
techniques in detailed videos stay tuned
for
more get more notes and flash cards in
our Facebook page or Instagram page
links are provided in the description
you can support our Channel using PTM
PayPal or UPI see you in next
video